[Music]  invention actually is the nectar  is the thing that's critical to progress  and  mit is a place which is about invention  [Music]  i suppose there was a sense of slight  coming home finding this place  it does just as there seemed to be a  different level of  exceptional focus on  progress through ideas and developing  those ideas  whether you call something design or  engineering or  architecture to me it's all the same and  it felt like  mit did put it all together and  was about ideas so getting this letter  suddenly saying  you you're you're being offered this  incredible  honor or award it's  my heart sort of went ah as a as a sort  of link to somewhere  whose values i i cherish  [Music]  you